Yeah.
In this video,
we'll start our discussion on the
application of neural networks to computer
vision problems.
So we've looked so far the fundamentals
behind a fundamental ideas behind neural
networks and concepts.
And now we'll start looking at a
application of neural networks to specific
problems. And this first series
of videos will look at, uh,
specifically at computer vision problems.
Uh,
computer vision is the design of
computers that can process visual data.
So images or video to accomplish some
given tasks that humans can accomplish
easily. And, uh, specifically in the, uh,
this video in the upcoming videos,
we'll focus on the problem of object
recognition, visual object recognition.
So in that context, uh, the,
uh, computer or the, the,
the program is giving us
input and image and a,
the computer must identify what's the
identity of the object that's present at
the center or more or less at the center
of the image. And so for instance,
we have an example here from the very
famous caltech one o one data set to data
set of how a hundred 101,
a different objects for which,
uh, we have, uh, several examples
of images of those objects.
And, uh, for instance, we
have an example here of a,
the image of a sunflower,
which is 112 pixels by 50 pixels and
the computer must take that as input and
then tell us at the
output that, uh, this uh,
particular image contains the image of a
sunflower where sunflower is one of the
101 different categories in the Caltech,
one on one data center.
So what we'd like to do is design neural
networks that are specifically adapted
in design for computer vision problems.
Uh,
the reason for that is that
Darson and issues with, uh,
the type of data we have to
manipulate in computer vision.
And there are certain characteristics
of the data we can also explore to get
better results.
So when the issue we have to think
about is that images are extremely high
dimensional inputs.
Uh,
so we've have an image
of 150 by 150 pixels.
Then what we'll have to manipulate
really is 150 times 150 different inputs.
So 22,000 times, sorry, 22,000,
500 different inputs.
And that's what gray scale images where
each input would be the intensity,
the grayscale intensity
of each, uh, pixels.
If we have RGB images and colors,
then we have three times as much input
elements that we have to manipulate.
So this means a lot of
parameters and this means a,
so we can be, uh, quite a
susceptible to overfitting. And a,
this also means a lot of computation
time if we're not careful. Okay.
Uh, but also image data is, is
particular, uh, for instance,
the order of the inputs is uh,
actually meaningful. In fact,
more specifically,
uh,
the pixels where each pixel is in
actual input for our neural network is
organized in a particular to d topology.
So pixels are organized spatially,
uh,
where a certain pixels are close spatially
in other pixels are actually far away
from each other in the specialty.
And the image a for video data.
Then we have a three d topology
where pixels are organize both,
uh,
spatially and through time.
And so that's something we
might want to explore it.
And also thinking about object
recognition Darson and then variances in,
uh,
the way an input image might change,
which actually doesn't change the
identity of the object in the image.
So for instance,
if we take an image and we take the
object in it and we actually translate it,
then that should,
that doesn't change the fact that the same
object is actually present in the, uh,
in the image. If we change the
amount of illumination, uh,
in the scene where we're
taking a picture of the image,
that doesn't also change the identity
of the object in the, in the scene.
And so that's also something we
would like to explore it in a,
ideally to build some invariants and be
able to generalize to new pictures of
the same object where the position,
the exact position of the object that's
changed or the elimination has changed
in the scene.
So we'll focus on a type of
neural net that tries to, uh,
exploits these. I explain these
ideas to get good performance.
They're known as convolutional networks,
and there are characterized by three
different properties that a really defined
convolutional neural networks.
The first one is local connectivity of
the hidden units, meaning that each shit,
and yet it's going to be
connected only to a small,
a small local region in the
image, uh, parameters sharing.
So the hidden units,
a lot of the hidden units,
we'll share parameters with
each other. And then, uh,
the use of a pooling and sub sampling
operations between a hidden layers in a
compulsion and neural network.
So in the following videos,
we'll look at these three ideas separately
that really defined convolutional
neural networks.